[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo 26 minutes pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
dans le département
au sommaire de cette édition premier
conseil d'agglomération après la période
estivale
l'occasion pour les élus saint
quentinois de se pencher sur les
questions environnementales avec le plan
climat air énergie les détails dans
cette édition jeunesse ryder cup et
municipales 2020 les thématiques
abordées avec notre invité
nous recevons aujourd'hui marie
christine le tarnec maire de guyancourt
capitale mondiale du golf du 24 au 30
septembre
dans le reste de l'actualité nous
reviendrons sur le conseil municipal de
coignières avec l'annoncé d'une élection
municipale anticipée et sur la jungers
cup organisée à plaisir et comme chaque
vendredi
vous retrouverez votre rubrique ça s'est
passé un voyage dangereux dans le temps
grâce aux archives de tv 78,51 saint
quentin en yvelines a fait sa rentrée le
conseil d'agglomération s'est réuni ce
jeudi 20 septembre une séance marquée
par deux votes
l'approbation du plan climat air énergie
territorial pour lutter et s'adapter au
changement climatique et l'élaboration
d'un règlement local de publicité
intercommunale un reportage de mélanie
poquet s'aperçoit dans le diagnostic à
85% des habitants 50 en ligne pour des
déplacements moins 5 km utilise un
diagnostic menée pendant deux ans par
l'agglomération en collaboration
notamment être l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat lors du conseil
saint quentin en yvelines a approuvé le
plan climat air énergie territorial
c'est une vraie avancée
et mais finalement c'est surtout un
commencement maintenant ce plan va être
envoyée à l'autorité environnementale
qui ajoutera aussi ces modifications
qu'on sera obligé de prendre en compte
notre objectif aujourd'hui de lancer ce
plan à partir de décembre 2018
pour commencer la mise en application
des fiches actions des vingt-et-une
fiches actions à partir de 2019 et très
progressivement pendant six ans une
plateforme collaborative du nom
d'esquimaux va être mise en place
elle devrait voir le jour d'ici la fin
de l'année à l'ordre du jour aussi le
lancement d'un règlement local de
publicité intercommunal de l'ensemble du
pays on réglemente ce qu'on appelle les
lycées les ancêtres étaient près de 500
publicité et pré enseignes ont été
recensés sur le territoire saint
quentinois la volonté de l'agglomération
et de préserver les espaces naturels
l'environnement évidemment c'est le sens
du texte tout en garantissant aussi
l'activité économique puisqu'on a quand
même beaucoup de florent sur notre
territoire
donc voilà l'objectif c'est aussi
j'allais dire de faire un nettoyage
jusque ont souhaité aussi s'attaquer aux
anneaux grands axes structurants qui
borde aussi les centres commerciaux les
zones d'activités un règlement unique
sera établi pour le territoire
l'agglomération espère le voter avant la
fin de l'année 2019 sur notre plateau
marie-christine le tarnec nous a rejoint
bon soit françois alors vous êtes vice
présidente en charge des sujets autour
de la ville et nos innovantes et maire
de guyancourt jeudi soir vous étiez au
conseil d'agglomération donc en tant que
vice présidente en charge de la ville
innovantes concernant ce plan climat air
énergie territorial comment vous engager
dans ce plan alors c'est vrai que c'est
un enjeu de taille et pour une fois on
va pouvoir au niveau de l'agglomération
réfléchir ensemble discuter voir comment
effectivement notre agglomération va
pouvoir être une agglomération durable
avec des économies effectivement
d'énergie mais aussi travailler sur nos
nos terrains agricoles puisque on a de
la chance sur ça quand on y vient
d'avoir beaucoup de terrains agricoles
moi je suis sur wii en cours par exemple
on a sanctuarisé effectivement plus de
120 hectares et puis on a toute une zone
encore des terres agricoles
et puis ça va nous faire aussi réfléchir
alors moi par rapport à ma la vice
présidence eh bien je travaille j'essaye
de travailler sur des nouveaux quartiers
sur lequel on va pouvoir apporter un
petit peu d'innovation par exemple les
le mobilier urbain pour pouvoir faire
des recharge de voitures électriques par
exemple ou des choses comme ça et c'est
un vrai enjeu effectivement ce plan de
développement durable sur sur 50 ha
c'est un défi pour nous aussi les élus
puisque il va falloir qu'on trouve des
des sujets communs qu'on va pouvoir
monter parce que dans nos communes
on a des autour du développement durable
et diversité c'est des décisions
différentes dont il va falloir un moment
qu'on fasse n'est pas les uns vers les
autres parce que de toute façon on n'a
pas le choix
la nouvelle génération on ne peut que
effectivement faire des économies
d'énergie et penser la biodiversité afin
de choses comme ça
alors concernant la nouvelle génération
justement vous vous engagez aussi à
guyancourt vous inaugurez sur vendredi
deux lieux destinés aux jeunes le street
work out est le phare jeunesse alors une
précision sur ce terme anglais le strict
workout où on voit leezam à l'image
ce sont des appareils de sport pour
faire de la musculation travailler son
endurance
des installations qui sont situées au
bord de l'étang du moulin à vent
marie-christine le tarnec pourquoi avez
vous décidé d'investir dans ce type
d'infrastructures alors guyancourt a
toujours été la ville de l'enfance mais
les enfants heureusement grandissent et
ont besoin de deux choses différentes et
là on avait fait deux sur ce mandat là
de la jeunesse une de nos priorités
on a une grande consultation jeunesse en
2016 où il ya plus de 800 jeunes qui
n'ont effectivement ai répondu et on a
vu leurs attentes et leurs besoins est
effectivement une de leurs de leur
demande c'était d'avoir des espaces
comme le streak work out mais aussi le
skate park qui va être inaugurée lui un
petit peu plus tard puisque le stream et
south et c'est cet après midi et c'était
leur demande alors ok je me suis engagé
effectivement les réaliser
mais pas que ce soit nous qui faisions
effectivement à totalité dire que je
leur ai dit ok mais vous participez donc
il ya eu des groupes de travail les
jeunes sont venus ont travaillé et sur
cet équipement cet après midi qui va
être ouvert et bien ils ont vraiment a
fait un travail important avec les
services techniques de la ville
ils ont été voir effectivement dans
d'autres communes
comment cet effet c'est eux qui ont
choisi les modules et puis bah en plus
cet après midi on aura la chance d'avoir
le champion du monde de stream world out
qui va nous faire des démonstrations et
ces jeunes qui ont participé à ce groupe
de travail seront effectivement présents
et alors juste après toujours vendredi
soir vous inaugurez aussi le phare
jeunesse qui est situé près de la maison
de quartier théodore monod un lieu
destiné aux jeunes de 16 25 ans alors
pouvez vous nous expliquer la mission de
ce phare jeunesse qu'est ce que c'est
alors c'est ce que je disais en
préambule c'est que à guyancourt on
avait beaucoup travaillé jusqu'au
jusqu'à la plage la tranche d'âge de 11
ans et on n'avait rien effectivement
pour pour la suite donc on a vraiment
fait de ce mandat un travail très fort
sur la jeunesse et les jeunes nous ont
aussi de demander d'avoir un lieu où
tout pouvait être à disposition tiers
qu'ils pouvaient trouver des
informations sur l'horizon orientation
ce qui est important lors des
informations sur par exemple sur la
santé parce que ça sert ses revenait
aussi assez souvent sur la consultation
lors de la consultation mais aussi à un
endroit où on pouvait les aider à monter
des projets alors quand j'entends monter
des projets sait faire avec eux et pour
eux mais pas faire à leur place
donc cette structure là elle est à eux
elle est pour eux on va les aider on va
les accompagner pour monter les projets
parce qu'ils sont demandeurs de projets
mais de tous niveaux un des projets
effectivement qui peuvent être autour de
la musique hop autour des anciens enfin
voilà énormément de projets et là nous
on veut être à leurs côtés effectivement
pour pour les aider il ya toute une
équipe pluridisciplinaire qui les attend
donc voilà il ya une petite salle aussi
vous pourriez avoir des répétitions
d'une
zik de danse ce soir d'ailleurs pour
l'inauguration on a tout eu beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes qui se sont proposés
pour faire effectivement l'animation en
dansant chanson il ya un an il ya un
humoriste aussi et voilà donc j'espère
que ils vont découvrir bon ils vont
découvrir pour la plupart seuil haut ce
soit et qui vont investir c'est ce qu'on
attend alors justement si vous êtes
guyancourt toi un jeune billancourt toi
donc je rappelle âgés de 16 à 25 ans le
phare jeunesse c'est 10 place bérégovoy
vous allez voir l'adresse s'afficher en
bas de l'écran et le numéro de téléphone
n'hésitez pas à appeler pour connaître
les horaires d'ouverture alors un tout
autre sujet on va vous amener à la world
cup alors c'est la ryder cup débute la
semaine prochaine mais la world cup
s'est poursuivie ce jeudi soir le
principe c'est une compétition de nos
logiques entre les vignobles américains
et les européens après le deuxième jour
de compétition l'amérique conserve la
tête devant l'europe avec un point
d'avancé ce concours l'occasion aussi
pour le réseau art partage de vendre des
oeuvres d'art pour récolter des fonds au
profit de l'association handigolf
écouter les acteurs de cette vente
représente lors de cette soirée à
travers le monde rigole ça permet à des
gens handicapés de se réaliser deux de
jouer comme des valides
c'est une des vertus du golfe alors donc
ça m'intéresse
et comme les photos que nous avons fait
c'était à propos de la ryder cup
on a promené des mannequins sur des
lieux un peu différent dont le dit le
green du 18 du golf national
l'endroit où va sans doute se jouer la
ryder cup donc il ya des artistes qui
valent
sinon un certain regret dossier wendel
important on va essayer de faire au
mieux
dans toutes nos deux dernières manches
de la ryder cup durant la semaine de la
ryder cup le 27 septembre
marie-christine internet du lundi 24
septembre au dimanche 30 septembre des
millions de personnes auront les yeux
rivés sur saint quentin en yvelines et
sur wii en cours c'est près de 60000
spectateurs qui sont attendus chaque
jour au golf national pendant la ryder
cup c'est une excellente opportunité
pour vous en faites
alors je vous ai entendu parler de
capital du golfe effectivement donc à
guyancourt va accueillir pendant toute
cette semaine plus de 70000 personnes
par jour c'est un défi très important
effectivement pour accueillir toutes ces
personnes c'est un focus sur notre ville
et sur saint quentin en yvelines qui
effectivement très très important on est
ravis d'accueillir cette grande
compétition
on a essayé au sida propos de faire en
sorte que les uhlans courtois puisse
s'approprier cette grande manifestation
donc depuis de nombreuses années nous on
a mis en place différents événements
comme le festival festigolf pardon on a
eu la chance d'avoir les deux capitaines
aussi qui sont venus discuter avec des
élèves de nos écoles élémentaires qui
travaillent autour du golf avec les
carnets de golf de l'éducation nationale
depuis quelques temps et puis on va
ouvrir on a ouvert une classe golf au
collège des sceaux depuis la rentrée de
septembre qui va être inaugurée
officiellement d'ici quelques quelques
semaines et puis on va terminer par un
grand événement qui sera le 29 septembre
devant le phare jeunesse et la maison de
quartier mono autour on appelait ça le
swin golf autour effectivement du golfe
et on terminera par un concert parce que
je dis aussi que le golf on a de la
chance d'avoir une compétition
internationale à nos portes mais le golf
restera sur guyancourt et oignons
continuera effectivement faire en sorte
que dès qu en courtois puissent
découvrir ce golf et puis continuer
aussi à avoir des jeunes puisque j'ai eu
aussi plaisir d'apprendre qu'il y avait
une association de wolf qui s'étaient
créés sur lui en cours donc ça veut dire
que ça va perdurer
marie-christine internet qui est resté
avec nous chaque vendredi dans l'hebdo
nous vous ouvrons les portes de nos
archives
retour sur les événements qui ont fait
l'histoire de saint quentin en yvelines
avec notre ca c
c'est un retour vers le passé signé
wilfried richy
[Musique]
troisième volet de notre est ça s'est
passé aujourd'hui nous avons retrouvé
les images de l'inauguration du théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui se trouve sur la commune de montigny
le bretonneux elle c'était le 27
septembre 1993
une inauguration après trois années de
travaux pour ce qui était à l'époque le
plus grand théâtre réalisés en ile de
france
ce jour là le public était accueilli en
musique et découvrez ce nouveau lieu
monumentale à de création et de
diffusion de la culture qui se distingue
par son architecture originale mariage
de béton brut de pierre de métal et de
verre et stanislas feeds heures et le
scénographe michel rioux alec en sont
les artisans à la place georges pompidou
est métamorphosé saint quentin en
yvelines est encore une agglomération
bien jeune et pour son directeur de
l'époque pierre moutarde une telle
aventure a toute sa place ici il y a eu
un travail pendant
près de vingt ans à elancourt de la part
de mes prédécesseurs et de la part de
toute une équipe qui a conduit à
l'existence de ce théâtre
et puis aussi parce que je crois que
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et au delà mérite quel est son
lieu théâtral 25 ans plus tard le pari
semble plutôt réussi avec une volonté
d'ouverture au plus grand nombre et qui
a contribué à donner une âme à saint
quentin en yvelines regarder encore ces
quelques images tournées le 23 septembre
93 où l'on voie publique
artistes et élus se côtoyer on notera
d'ailleurs que le tout nouveau préfet
adresse lors de ce moment l'un de ses
premiers discours dans le département
claude erignac
il restera en poste jusqu'en 1996 avant
d'être nommé en corse depuis près de 20
ans l'état la réaction du ministère de
la culture
ce souci de soutenir une action
culturelle qualité au sein de la ville
nouvelle de saint quentin en yvelines
il l'avait notamment en contribuant
largement à la construction de ce triage
une remarquable lèche architectural est
écrit c'est lui dire les relevailles de
jacques toubon ministre la culture et de
la francophonie
il m'a demandé d'excusés sur l'absence
est de vous adresser ses voeux succès
[Musique]
alors on marie christine le tarnec
c'était il ya 25 ans et vous y étiez
alors oui je sais très agréable de
revoir à ça puisque c'est vrai que quand
il est arrivé ce théâtre là on s'est dit
puisque moi ça fait trente huit ans 39
ans que je suis sûr si on lui en cours
on s'est dit ah là on aura pu aller sur
paris on pourra avoir des grands
spectacles juste à côté
et puis aussi une pensée mais aussi pour
claude erignac était un préfet qui
malheureusement a perdu la vie quelques
temps après on passe tout de suite au
résumé de l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
une élection municipale anticipée à
coignières après la démission du maire
jean-pierre sevestre et d'une partie des
conseillers municipaux lassitude la
situation était devenue intenable
une décision suite au conseil municipal
qui s'est tenu ce mercredi 19 septembre
un reportage de wilfrid richier et de
grégory canal et c'est un conseil
municipal incomplet qui s'est réuni
mercredi soir à coignières après la
démission du maire et de trois autres
conseillers seuls 25 des 27 sièges
étaient pourvus face à cette situation
le préfet a décidé de convoquer une
élection partielle intégral la commune
de coignières va se représenter devant
les électeurs ce que je trouve très
démocratique si en quoi n'y a rien de
voir l'équipe qu'elle veut avoir pour
gouverner cette ville dominique catelin
qui sera selon toute vraisemblance tête
de liste lors du scrutin la date du 25
novembre est avancé en attendant le
conseil municipal se chargera comme le
veut la loi de gérer les affaires
courantes
lors de la campagne la voie du deuxième
adjoint du maire démissionnaire avec qui
il était rentré en conflit
elle devrait se faire entendre je vais
essayer de réunir surtout l'équivalent
d'une trentaine de personnes et les
faire intervenir et agir vraiment pour
qu'elle soit motivée pour shu qu'elles
choisissent elles mêmes les têtes de
liste je suis pas pour le culte de la
personnalité en ce qui me concerne je
l'ait jamais été donc voilà par contre
si c'est choisi effectivement en toute
conscience et en toute liberté par un
groupe
ma foi à mes yeux ça une valeur morale
moral plus importante
et puis candidat a déjà déclaré didier
fischer l'opposant socialiste qui en
2014 avait totalisé 43 % des suffrages
séparaient la meilleure des solutions à
l'heure actuelle compte tenu des
divisions de la majorité
compte tenu du fait que de toutes façons
on n'était plus en mesure de gérer
correctement cette ville bientôt on
allait avoir le
le budget complémentaire à voter ce
budget complémentaire n'aurait pas pu
être votée à partir de ce moment là nous
aurions été dans une situation de
blocage et c'est préjudiciable aux
poignets rien et la ville d'une manière
générale reste à savoir si une fois élu
le nouveau conseil pourra mettre les
rancoeurs deux côtés d'autant que les
dossiers importants ne manquent pas et
notamment celui d'une participation à la
création d'une piscine intercommunale
avec maurepas elancourt vous venez de le
voir marie-christine le ternen
jean-pierre semestre qui a démissionné
une partie du conseil municipal qui
démissionnent qui entraîne
l'organisation d'élections municipales
qui auront lieu courant novembre à
coignières votre sentiment concernant la
situation politique de cette commune
alors je ne me permettrais pas de
prendre de position
c'est aux habitants effectivement de
coignières de décider quelle équipe ils
veulent la seule chose que je peux dire
c'est que effectivement il risque d'y
avoir une une liste ps du gauche et que
sur la les élus minoritaires de la
communauté d'agglomération on risque
d'être peut-être un peu plus nombreux
maintenant c'est aux habitants de
choisir alors les prochaines élections
qui vont vous concerne et c'est en 2020
je vais être direct qu'est ce que vous
serez candidate en 2020 alors ces
questions elle se pose pas aujourd'hui
pour l'instant ma priorité c'est de
pouvoir réaliser la totalité des
engagements que nous avions pris
effectivement vis-à-vis du
dd guyancourt toi on porte avec les élus
de ma majorité effectivement un projet
de vie qui est qui est ancré dans les
valeurs de gauche qui sont solidarité et
l'éducation bien sûr développement
durable et la défense des services
publics
voilà ma priorité pour l'instant c'est
de réaliser effectivement les
engagements pris devant régulant
courtois donc vous me poserez la
question à un autre moment
à quel moment on verra alors lui il a
déjà assuré
il est déjà assuré d'être candidat en
2001 puisqu'il l'a annoncé stéphane
mirambeau maire de villepreux a annoncé
aussi son ralliement au mouvement la
république en marche
une décision prise en avril 2017 mais il
a souhaité attendre avant d'officialiser
son soutien alors stéphane mirambeau
vous le connaissez pas ce que vous
siégez à côté de lui il est vice
président chargé des finances à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
il conserve son poste malgré son à
l'immense ça ne change pas son
basculement dans la majorité
votre réaction par rapport à ça tout
simplement alors c'est une décision
personnelle
moi je suis et je sais qu'en tant qu'élu
minoritaire à la communauté
d'agglomération ça n'a aucun impact
maintenant je vous invite à poser la
question à monsieur fourgous président
de l'agglomération de saint quentin
puisque monsieur mirambeau et son vice
président en charge des finances
marie-christine le tarnec me merci
beaucoup je rappelle que vous êtes maire
de guyancourt vice présidente en charge
de la ville innovante l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un excellent week-end mercier une
page économie à un nouveau bâtiment pour
le groupe socotec cette entreprise de
contrôle dans le secteur de la
construction a inauguré son nouveau
siège social à guyancourt lundi 7
septembre une nouvelle installation qui
intègre les trois anciens sites déjà
installés sur l'agglomération or
regardez c'est une entreprise historique
de saint quentin en yvelines le groupe
socotec a inauguré son nouveau siège à
guyancourt
installé depuis 1979 sur l'agglomération
elle a regroupé ses trois sites et ses
450 salariés sur un espace de 7000 m²
avec un attachement certain au
territoire
alors ce nouveau siège qui représente
d'abord
un environnement de travail radicalement
nouveau pour les 450 collaborateurs qui
travaillent ici beaucoup plus ouvert
beaucoup plus fins facilitant le travail
en transversal exprimant beaucoup mieux
ce que doit être un environnement de
travail
aujourd'hui en 2018 présents lors de
cette inauguration jean michel fourgous
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et marie-christine le tarnec maire de
guyancourt travailler main dans la main
avec les entreprises saint-quentinoise
la volonté des élus vous savez 51 c
c'est en fait que j'ai trouvé c'est un
trip le pôle d'excellence excellence
sportive ya qu à voir aujourd'hui dans
quelques journaux lier cup c'est un pôle
d'excellence économique la qualité des
entreprises cinquantaine n'est plus à
démontrer elle est allée assez
extraordinaire et puis aussi un pôle
scientifique avec également l'arrivée de
paris saclay la première université
française qui va être le le pôle
scientifique et technologique delà de la
france des entreprises sur une collector
une collectivité c'est très important au
niveau du budget avec la baisse des
dotations effectivement de l'état ça
nous permet d'avoir des financements
importants pour mettre du service public
à disposition des habitants
socotec réalise aujourd'hui près de 700
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
spécialisée dans les tests l'inspection
et la certification dans le domaine de
la construction et des infrastructures
avec ce nouveau site le groupe a pour
ambition de devenir le leader européen
du secteur du sport et la fièvre de la
ryder cup a également touché
l'université de versailles saint quentin
la structure a organisé mercredi et
jeudi la jungers cup une compétition
étudiante opposant des golfeurs français
et étrangers sur le thème de la ryder
cup
un reportage de michael et demi d'euros
des poules aux rouge et bleu sur un
parcours de golf ce mercredi 19
septembre l'esprit de la ryder cup s'est
emparé du golfe isabella de plaisir à
l'occasion de la première édition de la
young heart cup
le concept la compétition oppose des
étudiants français et étrangers
rendez vous imaginé et organisé par
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
pour martin en personne était la mère
murger comme ainsi fallait que j'ai à la
fois des relais au niveau des étudiants
français dont j'ai sollicité
et professeur des universités
franciliennes et du côté étranger dans
un premier temps j'essayais d'avoir des
relais auprès des écoles britanniques
américaines de la région parisienne
au total quatorze joueurs lui français
six étrangers ont répondu présents pour
ce rendez vous elle se trouve que l'idée
super cool de faire une compétition
juste avant la ryder cup pour avoir le
feeling had
oui j'aime j'aime bien ça permet de
vivre un peu mieux la ryder cup un peu
plus ensemble voilà c'est génial parmi
les étudiants on retrouvait notamment la
fille de la légende du golf français
jean van de velde joueurs sur la ryder
cup en 1999 étant franco suisse
alexandre a enfilé le temps d'une
journée le polo des états unis et non
pas de l'europe comme son père ça me
fait un peu bizarre je pense que mon
père va être content mer après les
matches la journée s'est terminée au
club house par un quiz sur la ryder cup
les deux équipes ont dû se creuser les
méninges pour répondre à une dizaine de
questions de culture générale sur la
compétition dans la mesure où cet
événement est porté par l'université il
fallait qu'il ait une petite connotation
donc culturelle et voilà donc on a
essayé de mêler culture et sport la
compétition s'est clôturé ce jeudi 20
septembre au golf de jardy à vaucresson
une deuxième édition pourrait être
organisé dans deux ans lors d'une
prochaine ryder cup et au final ce sont
les polos rouges qui se sont imposés les
golfeurs étrangers ont gagné d'un point
sur les golfeurs français
avant de terminer cette édition je vous
propose de notre nouvelle rubrique
l'actualité en ile de france
[Musique]
des journées sans voiture la mise en
place de la ligne est critères en
complément de la circulation alternée
différentes dispositions pour améliorer
la qualité de l'air en ile de france
mais les pics de pollution reste
toujours aussi fréquents durant la
période estivale
regardez ce reportage de nos confrères
de vie au grand paris depuis quelques
années la qualité de l'air en
ile-de-france ne se dégrade pas mais les
résultats ne sont pas pour autant
satisfaisant de nombreux polluants
dépasse encore les normes mais bien la
qualité l'air en 2017 s'il a assez
similaire à 2016 c'est à dire il
confirme une tendance à l'amélioration
de la qualité de l'air depuis depuis des
années mais néanmoins c'est pas parce
que la qualité de l'air s'améliore
qu'elle est satisfaisante et on a
toujours pour 5 polluants des gens qui
sont des millions de personnes qui sont
exposées à un air qui ne respectent pas
la réglementation et les normes
sanitaires les plus hauts pics de
pollution sont recensés en zone urbaine
au bord des axes de trafic les habitants
d'île de france et plus particulièrement
ceux de paris sont donc les plus exposés
une exposition non sans conséquence pour
la santé si vous habitez près de une
grande voie de circulation vous êtes
plus exposés vous avez plus de risques
de faire une maladie cardiaque et de
mourir d'une maladie cardiaque à une
étude qui avait montré que si vous
habitiez à moins de 50 mètres d'une voie
à grande circulation par rapport à
quelqu'un qui habite à 500 mètres d'une
voie de circulation vous avez + 38 % de
risques de faire une mort subite
plusieurs initiatives ont été mises en
place afin de diminuer la pollution de
manière ponctuelle comme les journées
sans voiture
mais à long terme elles ne sont pas
suffisamment efficaces il faut des
mesures permanentes
si vous voulez agir sur la qualité de
l'air que vous respirez toute l'année
tous les jours il faut des mesures
permanentes comme par exemple des zones
de basses émissions on va limiter
l'entrée des véhicules les plus anciens
par exemple dans paris et c'est ce qui
est discuté aussi au niveau de
l'agglomération parisienne l'été 2018 a
été marquée par un épisode de pollution
à l'ozone de record depuis 2003 c'est la
fin de ce numéro merci de nous avoir
suivis et retour de l'information dans
le 7-8 journal lundi à 18h10 il a passé
un excellent week end
[Musique]